I've talked about how a bc304 could not
go and save the crew of the destiny but
is there a way they could be saved by
the SGC
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so a couple of comments that basically
said a BC 304 at hyperspace could go and
save the destiny some people seem to
think that they could get there and back
within 90 days
I've done a video explaining why no they
can't and the destiny is at least three
billion light years away now predictably
in that video I got the math wrong I
knew I would
um I even said in the video that I would
and I did
I said that it would take five years for
a BC 304 to get three billion light
years out and that was a minimum
distance to the Atlantis
actually Mr zero or three billion it's
nine zeros not eight and it's actually
50 years to get out that far so 100
years round trip uh not very likely and
I was ignoring things like they'd have
to take food and stuff and Fuel and you
know not having to stop because the
engines would overheat and all those
other things so I was talking about an
absolute bare minimum now this ignited a
really fascinating debate loads of
people were thrown in the ideas though
about how they could actually be saved
one example was that how about a BC 304
or 305 306 you know it's been 20 years
since Stargate sg1 and Atlantis ended
How about if one of those vessels was
powered by a zpm now we have actually
got some estimates on that that a zpm
powered Starship was able to get to
Atlantis in about three days now we did
our previous maths based on a Starship
being able to get to the Pegasus Galaxy
in 18 days so six times faster
unfortunately that still means the BC
304 305 306 whatever would still take
over six years to find the destiny and
that's assuming you knew exactly where
she was and she was at literally the
minimum distance that Rush could have
meant when he said that they traveled
several billion light years
now three billion light years just over
six years seven billion light years a
bit more so traveling at hyperspace
regardless of how much power you've got
seems like a little bit of a waste of
time
another very popular option though is
Bill the Super Skate
the Ancients made the Milky Way galaxy
huttle because it was very very far away
from the aura Galaxy
the only way that all right could get
ships here was via the super game so
surely we could send supergate
find destiny
now we have no idea what their distance
was is it something like three billion
light years we just don't know but it's
far enough away that the aura couldn't
travel here in ships
so they built the super game could we
build a super gay also well that super
gate was powered by a black hole
that's a little bit difficult the aura
were very technologically advanced not
maybe as advanced as the Ancients but
well when they first got here they
kicked the asgard's ass so advanced
how would we even go about starting to
build a Stargate I have no idea we would
also have to somehow manage to get the
parts for a super gate to the destiny I
have no idea how we do that
but in theory the idea of building a
super gate if we could figure out how
and if we could get a black hole to
power it is a workable hypothesis but
it's based on many many assumptions that
we just don't know the answer to another
very popular solution to this problem
was the Atlantis itself now she has a
wormhole Drive
technology built by the ancients they
were able to get to earth virtually
instantaneously from Atlantis so the
Wormhole Drive could get us to the
destiny similarly as quickly but there's
a few problems with it for one this was
a technology that the Ancients couldn't
get to grips with they said it was
incredibly power draining now this is
coming from a race of people that had
zpms and they still said look this uses
a crapload of power
it's also very very difficult to control
a vessel actually within this Wormhole
traveling through space the calculations
were mind-boggling and it failed
repeatedly we also have to remember
though that Samantha Carter did tell
Shepard that the Wormhole Drive had been
burned out that it was virtually
destroyed and it was going to be very
very difficult to repair as they didn't
even know what some of the parts were I
think she said something along the lines
we didn't even know what to call them
never mind how to fix them now even if
they could reverse engineer this
Wormhole drive we have to remember that
the Ancients couldn't even get this
technology to work properly and you then
have to remember that the Asgard who
were way more advanced than us even
though we do now have their sort of data
core so we are going to be learning much
more about the Asgard technology but
even the Asgard said when they found
great libraries of information from the
Ancients they had barely been able to
scratch the surface of some of the
technology and some of the advancements
that they were able to achieve
so even though it has been 20 years
since the end of SG-1 and Atlantis I
very much doubt we're going to be
technologically advanced enough to all
of a sudden catch up to the Ancients and
build a wormhole drive better the one
they were able to build
going from Atlantis to Earth is about
three million light years and the
Atlantis barely made it Earth to Destiny
is three billion light years away
I don't think it's a practical solution
or at least not yet the destiny has been
leaving a bunch of gates behind it as
it's been on its merry travels so could
those Gates be used to jump home now
yeah why not the problem is there's
probably millions of those Gates and it
will probably take
decades to get home I'm completely
guessing I have no clue the other
problem is you don't actually know what
you don't know so you don't know how
many of those Gates have been destroyed
how many of those gates are just left on
what asteroids or that in the millions
and millions of years since they were
deposited whether they're still working
so you could start this journey and
suddenly find halfway that you can't get
any further
so a lot of people did suggest why don't
you just gate home using that maybe you
could figure out a way to sort of jump
from gate to gate very rapidly or
something
yeah the problem is again it's based on
loads and loads of assumptions that we
just don't have the answers to so
possibility now obviously the most
likely and the most obvious possibility
to get them home is to find a way to
connect a Stargate that they actually
have they got to their Destiny via
Stargate now fair enough that Stargate
was hooked up to a planet and powered by
a planet a planet that then exploded
when it was used so all right we might
have to destroy a few planets in order
to be able to do this it's also not as
easy as just you know getting to the
destiny and then going oh I'm going to
plug this into a planet we're going to
go home
the device that was plugged into it was
an ancient construction that was vast so
again not very likely but finding maybe
another power source maybe I don't know
a few zpms whatever and then being able
to connect an active Wormhole from our
galaxy to the destiny
send the power source through and then
turn around and come back that seems to
be really the only likely and only real
practical solution for getting that crew
home
we also have to think how many resources
of the SGC actually going to put into
this endeavor they don't really know
what the destiny is
the destiny is actually in herself are
not particularly technologically
advanced so they're not necessarily
going to learn a great deal on a
technological level at least from the
destiny her mission was actually
superseded by the city ships the
Ancients outgrew and never bothered
following through with the mission so
again from a practical what do we get
out of it point of view
I'd say that actual resources being put
into it would be limited so there are
loads of really good ideas and how we
could save the crew of the destiny but
what do you think what is your favorite
solution do you think this is a problem
that we must solve how many resources if
you are in charge of this would you put
into saving the crew or would you say
you know what
it's a shame it's sad but there are more
important things to worry about
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think
if you are new to the channel though
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and there is an
option for a seven day free trial so go
give it a look
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
foreign